we begin with the disturbing problem
inside what is the democratic socialist
party
the very same people screamed russia
russia russia
for years and years well they might want
to now begin
and take a long look in the mirror
because they must address what is an all
too cozy relationship
with all things china china china as we
have long documented on this program
beginning in january of 2018 with peter
schweitzer when secret empires came out
the people's republic of china is yes
these are other bad regimes
but it is the most malignant government
on earth
and that's saying something given the
other hostile regimes like russia russia
iran iran
but that did not stop zero experience
hunter biden
he was raking in millions in cash in
equity
from well-connected high-ranking chinese
nationals
and begging for millions more from a
chinese energy company
and breaking tonight according to text
messages obtained by fox news
we can report that hunter's now
ex-business associates
were actively looking for ways to quote
get joe
remember the big guy involved in their
china venture
and one of hunter's former partners even
texted quote
let's get the company set up and then
tell h
and family and the high stakes and get
joe
involved get joe involved let me repeat
why on earth would hunters business
associates want to get joe
biden involved with a private equity
deal in a foreign country like china
which is a hostile regime towards us
were they selling the access
again special treatment are they
compromised
in other words the former vice president
and his son
what does china have on them what
potential compromise can exist
and what does this mean for the country
but remember during a train wreck
interview on gma
zero experience hunter claimed he had
not received one cent
from his china deals now why would he
have said that
the johnson grassley report contradicts
that in detail that millions of wire
transfers yep
from china and the report also found
that hunter's family
went on a hundred thousand dollar
shopping spree
compliments of a chinese national member
tony babalinsky was on with tucker
hunter's former business partner
claiming that hunter received
direct payments from china even hunter's
own attorney was forced to issue a
clarification
after the disastrous gma interview
admitting his client received equity
well tends to be in the millions and
millions of dollars we now know
and breaking tonight a report from the
daily caller shows
that hunter biden was due to receive
massive payouts from a chinese equity
venture
starting in 2019 and continuing for a
quote a couple of years
in other words to put it simply as we
speak hunter or someone else in the
biden family
might well be receiving cash now from
china
joe biden wants to run this country his
son might
well be getting cash payments from what
is our number one
adversary the most malignant country in
the world
that is uh more than a little concerning
what if the last name was trump i wonder
how the media would react
that is worse by the way than anything
the russia collusion truthers
ever dreamed up but joe biden wants you
to believe this is nothing more than a
a big right-wing smear campaign take a
look
we have great confidence in our son
i am not concerned about any accusations
but made against him
it's used to get to me i think it's kind
of
foul play but look it is what it is and
he's a grown man he is the smartest man
i know
i mean in front of pure intellectual
capacity
um and uh and as long as he's good we're
good
as long as he's good we're good well
it's not good to me remember hunter
biden currently under a federal criminal
probe as we speak
involving international money laundering
tax evasion
this is not going away and it's not a
right-wing smear
this is an independent federal probe
that has nothing to do with president
trump
or his administration and now senator
rand paul
he is rightly calling on the feds to
treat hunter just like they would treat
anyone else connected to trump or his
campaign take a look
if he's confident he should leave in
place the u.s attorney who's
investigating hunter biden
there is a u.s attorney in delaware
doing this traditionally when a new
president comes in they fire all the u.s
attorneys
if he wants to show that this is going
to be a upright
upstanding biden administration and that
they're going to
actually let the cards lie where the
cards lie on hunter biden
he needs to leave that u.s attorney in
place so that's something very carefully
to watch
if the u.s attorney is fired in the
first weeks of the administration
and if the investigation goes to a biden
appointee you can tell the fix is in and
there's not going to be justice
but hunter biden deserves the same
justice that paul manafort got
nothing less nothing more okay no matter
what happens with the investigation at
least zero experienced hunter will
always have
something to fall back on and breaking
this week despite
no real experience in the art world well
it appears that
zero experience hunter was able to land
a solo
show at a prominent new york art gallery
hmm wonder how he got that i'm sure it's
his great talent
and of course the biden family is not
the only liability inside the democratic
party
house intel committee member eric
swalwell as you know
had a years-long relationship with a
reported chinese spy named christina
fang
swalwell to this day refuses to answer a
single question
about whether or not the relationship
was more than platonic which could make
a difference
but fang has been accused of sleeping
with many politicians across the country
it does raise the question what if
anything did he divulge in terms of
state secrets being on the house intel
committee
to this spy that he was hanging out with
a lawful lot
who got an intern in his office and she
was raising money for
we don't have an idea and this has been
hidden from the american people for a
long time
swalwell another russian truther
uh it refuses to answer any of our
questions take a look
congressman smallwell do you do you plan
on stepping down from the committee
or anything like that or resigning from
congress can you tell us anything about
your relationship with miss fang
anything in general
remember from smallwell
so what did he know when did he know it
when did what did pelosi know when did
she know it and the same would go for
the corrupt congenital liar
the compromised one himself adam schiff
at the very least swalwell must be
removed from the intel committee
he's had a long relationship with the
chinese spy
she placed an intern in his office his
judgment is clearly lacking
he can't be trusted with state secrets
plain and simple
imagine the outrage in the mob the media
big tech
and the democrats if swalwall was a
republican or god forbid he had the last
name trump
the reaction would be apoplectic the
coverage would be filled with breathless
hysteria
second after second after second of
every day